i didn't have my first sexual interlude
was 21 which is ancient
for the 60s you're talking peace and
love in the 60s and my brother goes hey
what's wrong with you man i said nothing
shut up what the [ __ ] is going on i like
to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
[Music]
okay you guys
sophie and i really
did not want to do an intro for today's
episode because our guest is so
phenomenal
that one was not needed
this guest has been a long time coming
known for his extensive music career he
has three platinum albums 10 gold albums
and has even acted in over 60 films but
aside from being an excellent performer
our guest was once an amateur boxer was
accidentally shot in a gun store and can
tell you random facts like no other this
grammy and golden globe nominated artist
pushes our buttons like no one else this
is our uncle frank oh thank you my
lovelies
frank stallone people my little sweeties
thank you oh thank you you know i was
kind of skeptical in the old days
because i heard they were doing a
podcast and they go hey do you want to
be honest
no there is so much crap about it i know
i know and i was so hesitant about
having you on in the beginning just
because i was so i'm a little bit of a
loose cannon yeah yeah but that's why
you're perfect for this podcast and the
brand of it you are truly unwaxed i am
on wax you are on wax unhinged
all of it so what was really interesting
was i was googling you the other day i
just wanted to get sort of your resume
what you've done and the first thing
that came up and i need you to clarify
this for me is your real name francisco
no actually it's frank stallone jr but
on my father's army thing it says
francesco so italia be francesco so why
does it say francesco online
i have no idea no one's ever called me
friendship why don't you just change
your name and tell a brand no no frank
is francesco would be a little too
greasy
i love darling my name is francisco yeah
i mean literally i mean kyle's work
really play up the old school italian
thing yeah i think we should just jump
right into your music career that's what
you're known for your guitarist a
songwriter your love correct me if i'm
wrong started with music when you were
very young yeah i started i mean
i started singing really kind of around
the house when i was five years old and
then i was very privileged to be at the
beginning of rock and roll because i was
over
which would be your great aunt my aunt
nancy who lived by the way the 99 wow
and
she spoke like it is she took a hit no
their whole podcast is going to be
accented yeah they're all off the boat
you know so so they go i hear it tonight
is the elvis guy gonna be on the tv so i
said okay so we all had dinner in those
days we'd all get together
the italian family and had sunday dinner
and ed sullivan which was the biggest
show on tv was on eight o'clock every
sunday for like 30 some years right it
was we're sitting there i'm with my
cousin eddie and diane and my father and
then the old adults off the boat
so all of a sudden right here
elvis
and man i i saw this guy go oh yeah this
is exactly what i want to be i mean the
floppy hair
oh absolutely wow oh yeah when he came
on well i mean i sang around the house
like you know goofy songs of the 50s but
when elvis came on it was like oh no one
ever seen anything like this in my life
of course my cousin eddie we're sitting
there going oh god this is so cool my
aunt and uncle said there jesus christ
what is he guy
with the dancing around the hair
flipping thank you very much
it was a phenom it was the one of the
most watched shows in the history well
that actually makes a lot of sense why
he would be your inspiration because the
way that you perform your stage presence
is so captivating you guys have similar
moves you have a lot of hips and you're
pointing to people and now i see a lot
of similarities between you and elvis
yeah the pointing yeah yeah well i think
he did a little better than me but other
than that i mean but
it was just it was just the phenom to
see i mean because he was like the best
looking guy in the world had the coolest
hair it was just all the girls yeah all
girls like today you have your your
idols but it was just bigger than
anything we had ever seen then i started
singing i was listening everly brothers
bill haley and the columbus all that was
real rock and roll radio and then of
course in 1963 when we saw the beatles
that put the nail in the coffin that was
you're like this is it
yeah i mean i so i witnessed the british
invasion of beatles and i witnessed
elvis on tv and i said this is it man
because i really was not a good student
you know i went to nine different
schools wait so i was gonna ask you
about that because i know my dad told us
that he was kicked out of 13. was that
kind of the same i didn't get he got
kicked out i never got kicked out he was
you are much better why did you get nine
different schools yes well because my
okay let's put in a nutshell this will
probably tell you why i'm not married my
mother is married five times my father's
married four times
yeah a really good blueprint out there
for like
you know for marriage good examples yeah
really good examples and everyone in my
family was divorced except my aunt
tatina who never came here she stayed in
italy she gave married for like 70 years
he was saying italy huh maybe he was
staying in italy not coming to
california yeah i mean by the time they
came over she was married already you
know 1932 when they came over wow but
your great-grandfather celester
sivestro he came over in like 1919
but he came over with my aunt he came
over with my aunt kellene
and in those days so he was a barber so
he worked and believe it was interesting
and like
11 12 years later he brings the rest of
the family over so he was gone for years
and years at time they're building and
you gotta bid for a guy that was born in
1883
he had his own barbershop so he was a he
was you know he did pretty well yeah he
did what he was the barber yeah because
of all of the different marriages and is
that why you guys were constantly moving
schools or why were you well schooled
yeah well we were in maryland sly and i
and we're going to school and then
my
mother
flew the coop
and so then i ended up
in mid-stream going to catholic school
which was night and day from public
school yeah catholic school they were
writing longhand we were still printing
this is the first grade right so
overnight i swear to god it was like i
was it was kidnapped like i was sitting
there hey
well what happened i came home and i
rang the doorbell and i sat there for
five hours no one came to the door my
mother had taken off she left my father
comes home wearing his you know hair
dressing outfit you know the tunic you
know the white like a doctor's smock
yeah
and he said pack up and i went to my
aunt roses that night went to catholic
school the next day and flunked first
grade so i have so many questions and
i was watching your documentary the
other day just because i wanted a
refresher on you and there's so many
stories of my dad being violent towards
you which i want to get into but what i
found interesting is that you mentioned
in your documentary that you even failed
music class oh this is your thing how do
you fail something that you're well to
savant
yeah you know what because
again in public school
you would think you'd start a little
slow in music but they start with like
shasta kovitch we're like
jimi hendrix what the hell is this you
know yeah right so
i brought in the first jimi hendrix
album are you experienced to music class
and the teacher goes okay frank let's
see what we have like almost like the
church lady you know yeah right so he
put it on it's like
purple haze and the class is going yeah
and he goes by the way that chord
notation is taken from a palabezian
but they started with the really heavy
classics right
tchaikovsky six which is i love all that
music now but it's hard for like a
12 year old brain to pull that out
wait so i this is totally off i saw the
guitar and i remember use one was their
first guitar that you bought and i
remember a story that dad also told me
that he stole a guitar for you
i had a lot i had guitars you know my
first guitar was a cheap guitar you know
my mother bought when my mother came
back after a while she had married this
other guy and she did a nice christmas
for us probably the only good one we had
but she i saw she bought two ukuleles
like with palm trees on them for my
brother and i thinking we're gonna be
like the everly brothers
simon and garfunkel within two hours he
smashed it over my head
broke both of them yeah he broke both of
them he also broke no but he also broke
all of your instruments everything
terrible
he was the original dennis the menace
yeah he's just just i think he i think
now
when i look back i think we both have
serious atd i mean i know yes yeah
absolutely and i don't think anyone knew
how to address it because he was very
hyperactive right and also he was a
little self-conscious about his mouth
and his right so a poor guy had the name
sylvester and he kind of had a crooked
mouth so he used to get picked on and he
would he had my father's temper he just
punched you right in the nose what do
you think
he was getting in fights every day so
then he kind of got into superheroes he
jumped off this the roof of the house
broke his collarbone
my father was like god damn it they're
not and my father was really he was
pretty mean yeah he was a little little
excessive yeah yeah yeah yeah well your
parents were a little bit little
excessive a little much i mean i
remember he can't understand to this day
yeah dad really beat the [ __ ] of me i
said sly
you snuck out of the house at 13 and
stole his cadillac and got into an
accident okay you know what that's why i
like talking to you that's true because
sly never tells the truth about a story
and we get the honest truth from you
that is true he stole a cadillac at 13.
my father's catalyst i would say and you
could correct me if i'm wrong that music
really gave you a direction and a
purpose so you had something to focus on
whereas he didn't really know what he
wanted he don't fight our flight the
whole time he had no direction he was uh
you know i mean but i will say one thing
we used to go to movies all the time
believe it or not it was 15 cents to get
in that's crazy how nice is that they
just park you there all saturday there'd
be three features funnies the newsreels
and we just sit there i mean for a
dollar you're like are you kidding it's
like we're rich candy was five cents so
he got into the soup i was into the
elvis thing he got into the hercules
super hero type thing mm-hmm
which is because he was skinny and again
when you had the name sylvester the big
thing there was sylvester the puddy cat
if you were going to
[ __ ] cat
yeah yeah
yeah he was always getting in fights and
he was tough he was wiry but he was he's
had my father's temperament he didn't
give a [ __ ] i know dad taught me growing
up all about like joseph campbell and
like greek mythology and all this fake
he wasn't talking about that then oh was
he not but maybe he's talking about
joseph campbell then no no he was
telling me about it now but i think that
makes sense why he was loving hercules
because we got all gods and stuff well
that was the thing you know because he
was skinny you know yeah do you think
that maybe at that time when you
found this thing that you really love
and you're pursuing it you're going for
it that he was resenting you because you
found yourself
right oh yeah he would always like i'm
saying i'd be going anywhere you walk
and punch me in the nose like for
nothing wait so why did you hire him as
a manager and i know it lasted once
yeah because i doesn't sound like a
manager i would want to hire oh god
deep down i think
me being i'm just a natural singer i
mean it was just natural for me i didn't
have to
and i think he resented it because he
really wanted to be a singer i can
attest to that because he'll sometimes
belt in the bathroom he's a horrible
singer horrible
but he tries he tries so hard
yeah yeah yeah and he would always bug
my band he'd come to rehearsal oh you
guys sound like a bunch of [ __ ] this
i should sing it
it was like all flat and the guys were
like
and they were afraid of them because it
was like bodybuilding we were like
skinny anemic looking rock stars there
like now right and why'd you hire him as
a manager oh i didn't hire him he hired
himself what happened was we went to a
place
on roosevelt boulevard where we lived in
philadelphia it's a place called jeans
on the boulevard
and i was definitely underage i was like
15 maybe
and he was well versed 15 he was like 18
19. but i think he was still under a
drink and he didn't read drink anyway
that much so
we go and there was a band playing the
soul tastics and of course he's sitting
there and he always had a lot of bravado
he would just go the neighbor
you know yeah he goes you guys sound
good man he goes there and then of
course he starts picking on me yeah you
guys you're dressed like [ __ ] this is
how you should dress i said he goes do
you have a manager they said yeah a guy
named jack mcquaid
and so he he cuts the card he goes well
who are you he goes i'm their manager so
he's like he just he insulates himself
put himself in
and he got us an audition with this guy
oh really wait in the afternoon
that now remember they're just phones in
those days you know
right right so we went down to this bad
neighborhood actually where
god i'm sick of these goddamn phones
that's i'm just turned it off i don't
want to hear from anybody
nobody that is
jennifer who is my jennifer sly probably
hello
who's this
oh man get lost it's like what was that
i thought it was sly he was like that
sounds like a woman did you hear that
that was weird that sounded like one of
your girls that was like what was yeah i
was like a martian or something no it
was like huh
and when i hear that you know i think
people try to be funny or use accents i
said you know you already sound like a
jerk officer
exactly anywhere else that like actually
kind of scared me no i thought usually
it's a sly
yeah and he would always have to call an
opportunity but i know if it's him he he
likes to facetime which i hate yeah he
does facetime all the time
i'm driving
hello what happened yeah one day last
one day what happened oh so we went down
we auditioned the guy liked us he goes
yeah but
you got to get outfits because we
dressed like kind of like the rolling
stones you know we were like into
so
i said what are we going to do we have
to get like outfits which i really
didn't want to do so we went down we
found a clothes door and if you see
pictures
we had these white
they're like heavy pants but they're
wide checked pants
and orange turtlenecks like wool pants
yeah stupid an orange turtleneck like
just the worst thing you could play in a
group horrible yeah we're sweating
yeah my hair was like curly i was trying
to straighten as i go on stage five
minutes
oh god what is with you guys that's so
long your hair that's a little bit like
a lot of sand no now your father had
totally straight hair up until now it's
a worse 50s no seriously he had he had
really thick straight hair
and i freaked him out when his hair was
getting curly because he's always teased
me i said how do you like it now pal but
his hair had really you saw like lords
of flatbush that's what yeah
yeah through all of this you actually
ended up being successful which is crazy
they started out in this like chaotic
kind of
childhood and like beginning early
stages of the career which you really
never know i mean i think that's how all
creatives are it's never going to be an
easier but you guys really had all the
odds against you everything we don't
have any i mean
the closest i mean no one has any talent
in my family i mean not my not you guys
but i'm talking like we're looking at my
answers
and stuff like there was no it wasn't
like you know but musical products you
and my dad really did have something
there like it was which is somewhere in
the gene somewhere somewhere i don't
know i i haven't seen it yet he
definitely can't cut hair for him like
he's the worst he's the worst sometimes
he's cutting my hair
and dyed our hair ruined it ruined it
completely demolished we do it all the
time we're in florida your ears look
you're going to cut it i go hey man yeah
being the little brother okay it's just
like it was chocolate
horrible horrible but you ended up
having a pretty successful career i mean
sistine and i we watched obviously your
documentary and just seeing your
timeline through it but what's
interesting is you know
of course every time you go up there's a
lot of disappointment that comes with
getting there
and
you were really vulnerable if you guys
haven't seen this documentary it's
called stallone frank that is i'll ask
you about the title it's on amazon prime
it's really entertaining and you've got
some great cameos in there yeah what for
conservative catholic we still won
six best picture awards no it's actually
a really fun watch but
i found out a lot about you and i didn't
know
that you're not really one to want to
share the stage with anyone i feel like
you've had a lot of groups you've had a
lot of bands but you're more of a solo
act yeah i'm not i'm not like it's john
oates yeah yeah yeah yeah john oates was
widely if you guys don't know who johnny
this is hollow notes hollow notes was my
lead guitar player your lead i was the
lead singer not him so how did that fall
apart well you know what like he was
going to college we were just you know a
rock band and you know like in those
days hey man i'm going to college and
travel europe you know with a bat
right right so he went off and then of
course he came back he was always good
friends with daryl hall and they start a
group and the rest is history well it's
so interesting because i went to a
concert a holo notes concert about
three years ago yeah it went about three
years ago and i somehow ended up
backstage and he came up to me and was
like i used to be in a band with your
uncle and talk all about you really yes
oh they introduced you as sistine
stallone i don't know what they did you
must have known your last name yeah
possibly because he was talking nice
the sweetest very nice but i thought
that was so i didn't know that you were
in a band with him i freaked out is that
wow i also want to talk about you were
really upset about being snubbed from
the academy award nomination
was it for far from over it was f for
best song and and the reason
i wasn't listen
i did i don't dislike barbra streisand
but that day i did but i think she's no
i think she's an iconic great artist but
this is what happened
the year 1983 and i came
you know from zip i mean i was i was my
brother's stand-in in rocky iii
and i sang so i got beat up by him in
the movie i got beat up by mr t and i'm
on stage singing so i was like the
singing heavy bag yeah right right right
and he always cheap shop he hit me hard
like you know so this is practicing uh
practicing for his role it's it's still
in his 30s still punching me right so
what happened there were five songs that
were nominated there was what a feeling
from flash dance maniac from flash dance
far from over from staying alive
one song from tender mercies that never
even charted past like 98 and one from
yentl barbra streisand that never gotten
to the
at the bottom of the chart that's a
pretty stocked uh
national group over was number one yeah
number one so was maniac and so was what
a feeling yeah what a feeling so i
figured
so i was doing my first album cover
shoot with one of the great he became a
very famous photographer greg gorman and
i was there with my girlfriend chelsea
she was one of the solid gold dancers on
tv it was like yeah
where's chelsea yeah we need to bring
chelsea chelsea's married to uh
the guy what's that famous
scott bakula i don't know who the hell
out of here she's got back they've been
on tv for like 80 years good for chelsea
good for her yeah
good for me good for you thank you very
much okay okay no no no no so uh
what happened so i'm doing the shoot
with my brother and we're having
champagne and that is the day they're
announcing
the academy you know nominations and i
wasn't expecting when i thought my
friend michael simbella was going to win
for maniac which i thought was a great
song
so but at least it would have been
really cool to have been nominated there
have been like two brothers
him nominated for rocky best writer best
actor and be
you know nominated for best song that's
amazing it would have been kind of cool
to be nominated incredible
so my brother calls i'm going to shoot
and i know it's he's yeah you're doing
his brother i sound [ __ ] here he
already knew no no i thought i said what
happened man he goes i got bad news i
said who died
i there was no way in my mind i thought
i was gonna lose my nomination there's
only five songs nominated right because
you lost your nomination i got one wow
oh that's impossible how could i lose
there are these five songs there were
five songs in the grammys five songs in
the golden globes and five songs in the
oscar you know what they did
mine was number one they took my song
out and put another barbra strider
oh so they put two for her two for her
and then and they bubbled under at 90.
they never even raided oh
this whole thing what's your most proud
moment as a musician i think my most
proud moment was
all the attention i got
when staying alive came out because you
have to understand i've been struggling
for 19 years since i was 15 years old
so it was you know and i was always you
know and especially you got i mean
before was one thing but when rocky came
out i mean i just got rocky to death
everything i did was like hey i like
your song hey what's it like being
rocky's brother i mean so that was just
like ah you know
something i couldn't get get away with
because you got to understand he was 29
i was 25. he was at the peak he was the
biggest movie star in the world peak of
his career so it wasn't like so it
wasn't like there was a handbook so what
do you do when unemployed actor becomes
the biggest movie star in the world
overnight yeah i mean what do you do
it's like the first viral
uh huge person because i mean today
that's like so huge
so actually is that why
then you named your documentary stallone
frank that is yeah because to kind of
highlight and kind of make fun of well
because yeah because they would always
do i do these cheap movies when i was
starting out
coming stone and then under it have
frank like this big and microscopic like
letters so they would sell yeah but
wouldn't that like hurt your feelings
just a little bit well of course i mean
but they had one thing christopher
mentioned myself to the movie
it was a horrible movie and but anyway
his father was robert mitchum was a
great star
so i saw the poster
and it says stallone
mitchum these huge letters and our faces
with the pistol it's the exact same
poster from nighthawks that's i know
exactly what you're talking about but
our names are this small it's stallone
this big and frank under there i just i
listen most these guys were cheesy
anyway they were just trying to like you
know sell it to like yeah i mean i feel
like that's like a sample or somewhere
you know well no they always try to do
that i mean with anything they're going
to put i mean it is still your name so
it's but it is it is something that
sofia and i can definitely relate to you
on
i think for a long time we really
struggled to find our own identity in
our own name and every time we did do
something or get a cool opportunity
people would say oh the door was open oh
you got it because of your dad etc etc
and it really takes
yourself to give you you know you need a
mental shift because you can either live
your life feeling bad for yourself or
just accept the opportunities that come
and sort of block out all the other
noises yeah listen you girls worked hard
to get this show going i mean the thing
is you'll get it i mean and if other
things happen in the future they're big
we'll all get it uh while any reason
their hair is
i said you know what okay they they said
that about me and staying alive i said
yeah but i wrote the songs no one wrote
the songs i mean that's the thing like
you actually put in the work you put in
the sweat the two they were lousy songs
as you know hollywood is not that
generous if they were not good songs
raw absolutely but they're not going in
the movie no and i have to give my
brother credit i mean thank god the bee
gees quit
or i wouldn't have been around because i
tried to
push my songs all the time yeah and
they're always like yeah it sounds
really good next i want to talk about
you on stage okay last time we saw you
you're playing at this really cool jazz
bar
and you're so funny because you talk to
the people you interact with the crowd
if someone goes to the bathroom you say
hey where are you going yeah pointed
them you said why do you do that well
you fly up yes
it's just that you know i think it comes
from all the years as i was telling the
gals before
when i was coming up like when your
father used to come see me i play four
shows a night that was 160 minutes of
music per night wow and me being the
main singer so that's five nights a week
160 minutes so it's a lot of time so
doing that it was a great breeding
ground for
dialogue talking to people because we
didn't have cell phones we didn't have
that stuff so when you you'd play 40
minutes you'd have 20 minute break you
go over talk to people at the bar the
girls whatever and you so you
learned it it's like when who
were you saying you wanted to do a
stand-up comic thing yes
it's brutal man let me tell you don't
even get me started i'm really thinking
this is a bad idea i think it's a real
bad idea but that's why it's going to be
fantastic because you die
alone and i got to i can tell you my
comedy career i'll tell you what
happened and you know i am funny yeah
you are funny when you find me out of
context i actually should take some
advice from you no i did i for one day
and i said this is not for me
i was playing at a place where your dad
went to college in coconut grove called
the flick it was a coffee house very
famous i was opening for
a few acts dion
it was a famous singer in the 50s and
someone else but for some reason i don't
know i just went through my set really
fast so i i'm going to say goes
hey kid where do you think you're going
i said well i'm done he goes now you're
not done you have to play for another 20
minutes i said i don't have any more
songs oh god well do something so i went
on stage you started doing and i didn't
have my guitar and i started doing
comedy stand up
it i got a standing ovation really so
the owner fired me as a musician and
hired me as a comic no way i swear to
god honey the next day i went on stage
and i died
so badly like i have a question i have a
question
you went up the first time no material
killed it just shooting the [ __ ] killed
it did you come in the next day having
some things prepared you're going to
plan on repeating what you just kind of
repeat wing it
and i realized that
comedy is really an art i mean that's
why these guys you see when they go on
stage they have tape recorders i mean
they really study what works and doesn't
work oh yeah it's very hard i mean guys
like bill burr you think it looks easy
but that's so nice timing it's like same
thing with being a stage performer like
years and years so hard are you planning
on getting back on stage soon possibly
in oklahoma city or atlantic city what's
happening i would like to play in
atlantic city and uh and have the family
come down see me because atlantic city
even though i'm not from new jersey i
lived there a long time that is kind of
my stomping grounds philadelphia
atlantic city delaware and some new york
and my friend is the ceo of the hard
rock
and i said man i mean don't you think my
show would be perfect for casinos
perfect perfect
yeah for casinos it's a very weird show
that's why i have a problem to go look
tell me what your show's like i go i
can't because no it's a lot of fun it's
so you can't really describe it yeah
honestly every single time i've gone to
your show it's been totally different
because i have
albums in big band and course stuff from
the movies and stuff so
it transcends it it's a very smooth
transition i might start out with but
cousins witchcraft
sinatra and then all of a sudden i'll go
and do
baby like a soul song yeah but it but it
but it just
slides into it and then all of a sudden
i'll do johnny cash ring of fire it's so
much fun and so it's really i hate to
say it because it sounds like a
schmaltzy like act hey there's something
for everybody but it's but it's rock and
roll i mean
like kings of leon i love the kings why
don't you sing that like something a
little bit more current too we gotta get
them on tick tock i'm like the worst i'm
definitely not current i don't even know
who drake is they go uncle frank
whatever
we don't talk about i don't know but i
know post malone is who i think is great
he loves milan i do like him i think
he's really good i think you guys would
be best friends but my favorite part one
of my favorite parts about watching you
perform is seeing all of the women in
the front row just swoon you know can i
tell you honest to god i swear to you i
promise i'm not even aware people go oh
you're in the zone what are you thinking
that girl's like i go where is she she's
because she's right here
in the front i all right but i'm really
kind of you can't tell me back in the
day you didn't notice oh yeah so i was
in a bar this big playing it was pretty
hard to notice the scary thing was there
is that
uh you know when i was a 22 year old kid
i was you know what they call full of
piss and vinegar and so we used to kind
of chase because i started late i didn't
have my first sexual interlude was 21
which is ancient
for the 60s you're talking peace and
love in the 60s and my brother goes hey
what's wrong with you man i said nothing
shut up yeah he was like a lecturer the
lecturer okay oh my god so i was a late
starter you have to understand in the
60s peace and love people were getting
laid you know whatever yeah but it was a
different era yeah and i was in the
music business but i was like i made it
like hey man you see what i did last
night like actually nothing so but i was
on stage and people so when i got the
opportunity to get my band together and
we were replaying those gloves we made a
i made up lost time yeah immensely so so
in terms of
catching up yes yeah and catching up
yeah because i was like 23 so the girls
were like 19 22. so is that is that why
you've stayed single forever like you
said the last time you had a girlfriend
was in the 70s 80s eight well you
brought over a few girls
and i really
a new girl but they were they're all
sweet they're nice my synopsis
i think maybe
you got heartbroken really bad once and
it just
could have left a scar did you ever have
you ever been heartbroken yeah of course
i mean yeah everyone gets heartbroken
it's just such a drag like you always
ask me uncle frank you've never owned a
dog
well either of you i mean we have family
dogs yeah that's true you don't have
like eight dogs so i never liked that
for 100 like one trillion percent i will
get my own dog eventually but you why
didn't you ever well you just i don't
want a dog on my own
it's a lot of work picking up poop first
thing in the morning is not my idea of
like sexy
hey honey i'll be out let me just pick
up some dog crap thank you straying away
from the animal talk when you were at
like the height of your career you said
staying alive you're doing i'd say that
with 83 that's when it all kicked in was
yearning for the respect that i yearned
for so many years and you've got a
fellow artist you got it yeah yeah
fellow artists coming hey man tina
turner came to the premiere staying live
she goes man you should write some songs
for me of course i should have because
the next year her album private dancer
sold 40 million copies why didn't you
because knucklehead i don't know why i
didn't
because you'd sly as your manager and
that was the problem no i
so you're at the height of your career
i'm sure women are
coming after you left and right did you
have a go-to line that was sort of just
in your back pocket that you'd always
use yeah what are you doing later that
was something
not easy i'm in town for a few hours
what are you doing
but i did have a girlfriend at that time
that was the dancer from staying up was
she your only girlfriend chelsea chelsea
yeah well then
yeah i mean i had i was
look i admit i'm a horrible boyfriend
i'm the worst why were you just not
consistent well i wasn't like the mo i
wouldn't say i was the most
honest boyfriend out there oh
because i figured and i think there is a
a protective
mode of protecting your emotions in that
way where on the other hand your brother
and i your father and i raised in the
same house but he always had a
girlfriend and i think because he's a
cancer which is the moon sign and of
course i'm a leo which is like you're
leo yeah are you into astrology just as
much as he is well i'm into it because
my mother was interested right nothing
people don't realize we're talking about
astrology we're not like just doing it
randomly grandmother
wrote books on it yeah so we do kind of
kind of and she was out there she was an
ass breeder
oh rhompology i said mom that's enough
why is there what are you kidding me let
me explain it really exciting have you
ever judged a girl on um her sign
i do it all the time really all the time
so what's your compatibility for me
probably aries leo maybe sag a scorpio
is a no-no for frankston yeah but
i'm really attracted to him but i know
it's just a disaster it's like they're
walking into a propeller
because it first starts good because
they're really sexy and they're like
funny but they're very very jealous deep
and emotional very possessive so the two
times i've like you said have my heart
broken both scorpios but i still keep
coming back like an idiot and it's like
but i know but so but now i predict a
disaster i know yeah it's gonna fail you
know sistine's a cancer i know she is
right i'm a virgo virgo and the scottish
one's a gemini but she is like a gemini
she's such a stretcher she's everywhere
she's everywhere
[Laughter]
well you sound like you're from
california even though you were born in
miami you're born and raised the only
time i was ever saw the girl's birth
well not birth that they was scarlet
really
yeah because you were born i was in
florida florida she was in you know
what year were you born 98.
i think i was fighting with your father
then i don't think we were talking yeah
i want to talk about that because um you
guys
brothers
very sensitive so it's very sensitive if
we feel like if i feel like sophia hurt
me right yeah i'm not going to lash
right back out and then forgive right
away like she would we honestly need to
remove ourselves for a certain period of
time
fights
blowout fights the scene has said to me
leave me because i'm one of those people
let's talk it out let's figure that out
and resolve it right now and you kind of
like to go in and it goes away for like
four hours and i'm reeling in my head
because i can't so i think my dad's the
same way but there was a bit of a
long-term separation
there was and i hate that because i love
my brother i mean i think he's one of
the funniest guys i've ever met yeah
he's sarcastically funny i mean he
really is funny yeah he is like were
having dinner and he mentioned like
something about now listen it's like you
don't listen if i say bali wants a
cracker and for some reason he said that
and we all started it just makes no
sense
his mother we were just cracking up
because what's so funny i said just why
that yeah everything cracker i know i
feel like we just make fun of the things
in his catch phrases but he is funny he
is funny but he's funny until he makes
you the punchline of the joke because
there has been
multiple times my whole multiple stories
of him just torturing you can i tell you
the true story about the stolen guitar
yeah this thing has been going around
since 1970.
and even her mother
in my documentary says sly has no memory
of anything she knows i always go to
frank
like it's a different story yeah it is
totally different he embellishes it okay
this is what happened
i was living
i think i was living in philadelphia and
i hadn't seen him probably a year and a
half until i moved to new york and we
were living together
and he went to i'm going to leave the
music store nameless in manhattan
and he walked in and it was a martin 12
string which at that time
350 was a lot of money in 1970 believe
it or not it's like like four thousand
dollars now
and he was there and he doesn't even
play
and he stole this
took the guitar ran out of the store
with this brand new martin guitar and i
don't know how he did it but he did it
so
he had this guitar for a few years it's
not like he stole it from me like i was
standing there hey here's your so all of
a sudden i said hey slime man what do
you what do you do with this guitar you
know when i moved to new york he says
i said why'd you take it
i don't know he didn't say he took it
for me oh he just he was a kleptomancer
he said that he took it for you he said
he wanted to win he hadn't talked and he
never gave it to you until years later
so then
and i said you did not steal me my your
father god rest bless him had very light
fingers in the old days he was just we
didn't have anything like
you know he always say he when he tells
the story of how he stole that guitar he
said it was one of the scariest moments
ever because it was a heavy guitar and
him running down that street trying to
be
secretive about it was impossible yeah
it was but i he didn't but so what
happened i traded it
oh yeah when i went to florida there was
a famous singer in florida who wrote
everybody's talking named fred neal and
he's just a great artist and there was
this cuban made 12 string called miguel
compagne which a beautiful guitar and
this guy had it plain i was looking to
go man because i loved fred neal it was
a beautiful 12 string and i had the
martin
and i liked the martin but i like that
one better so i i
wheeled and deal with this guy for like
five months he goes okay we'll trade and
then he got so mad well here's a
is that the martin i go yeah massimo
martin he doesn't know the difference
between guitars and they found that i
treat it you know i got going to jail
yeah he starts yelling
i said dude you didn't steal from me
because you had it for a few years
before you ever gave it to me and i
wasn't even living in new york
and john hirschfeld goes hey brother
john hurts felt like like our family you
know he's been sly's friend for how long
for like 50 50 six years yeah
and so that's what so i just said okay
man i'm sorry yeah
i can't win but he did not it wasn't
like
a burnt offering like he came home he
goes hey look what i got for you like
like like i had like a shoe box or
guitar or something no i would have to
say one of my favorite stories
ever between the two of you was i
believe you were in hawaii and there was
something to do with the black sea
urchin and your afro he's stuck at my
hip face and hair
basically i hate i hate skin diving so
we were to go hey you want to take skin
diving lessons and go not really and my
hair was like down to here it was curly
it was like this
and we're under there and he just cannot
help himself all of a sudden he pulls my
mask off
and i go into total panic mode i come up
i go what are you doing man
so then he finds a sea urchin he sticks
it like right kind of in my hair and
face and it just laughs you can't get it
it latches to his head so now i come out
of the water and look like a total [ __ ]
with the sea urchin like stuck in my
hair and he thinks it's funny yeah wait
how did you get it off to dftp i have no
idea how i got it i think i had to cut
some of my hair i was really pissed
cecina's philosophia yeah because you
know as you know you might have
philosophia falafel was i'm afraid of
falafels or what colossal phobia is fear
of default yes we hate groups like not
knowing what's underneath oh no oh no
yeah because we had a summer house man
and i was always afraid i was going to
snap step on one of those snapping
turtles that freaked me out
that's like i would be worse than sharks
but you know like oh no turtles but you
know as you talked in in my in my uh
documentary we talked about my
panic attack era which was horrible so
glad you brought this up actually that's
fine because this is something i would
love to touch on i never knew that you
suffered with anxiety and panic attacks
deadly and i really wanted to ask that
makes sense where i got it from no if
thank you guys but i want to ask how you
were able to cope with it in your
generation because today it's a
different time we have way more
was no resources so how did you go well
it just happened it just came upon me
one day and it was the most terrifying
thing it really is in my life because i
i said am i possessed by a devil now you
have weird thoughts you have gory
thoughts you have fear thoughts things i
think what saved me
was music because i when i be on stage
i'd be fine
but anything having to do with personal
that's probably why i didn't date or
things like that
and it's it's not so much the panic
attack it's the fear of one coming on is
scarier than thing really
yeah so but they didn't have anything i
mean i tried lithium you know this and
that but they didn't have any like xanax
then this 1960s and all of a sudden
you've you were i was ashamed like to
talk to anybody about the same i mean
what do you go to the doctor hey i just
felt i dreamed i threw someone off a
building to go really okay so you're
afraid because you're not in control of
those things your thoughts and you know
i think i never had them driving i've
had one i had one recently driving that
is not fun i pulled over and yeah whoa
what age should this start for you
19.
it started was about 19
to about
25 26 and i used to talk to your father
about it i said man i don't know i
thought i was possessed i said what did
i do it's so scary because you've never
talked to anyone about it and you're
afraid to tell you're afraid i mean how
do you talk to trying to meet a girl go
hey you know what i had these thoughts
the girl goes hey okay
i'm out of here i'm out of here so
eventually i i kind of outgrew it oh
really yeah i mean it it goes away
because then you know you realize that
because my my dad still suffers some
anxiety now i saw your father
and he developed panic attack i saw him
have one on the today show i saw it oh
yes
what happened
well he did the show you know i mean you
got to buck up and do the show but you
know frank
i'm dying
wait yeah yeah freeze it was terrifying
but yeah but uh
listen man
i wouldn't want i mean he's had a great
life but i wouldn't want to be the guy
that everywhere you go everyone knows
who you are i mean you really can't go
anywhere in the planet without being
recognized that's tough you're more of a
you like to stay sort of
under the radar
yeah i think more like the music thing
that's cool i like yeah but his thing i
this is before he met your mother and he
wasn't married at the time but we met
these two girls at the oakwood
apartments oh boy he goes in the school
visit them i said okay man i said but
you can't walk around everyone
ah don't worry about so he's wearing a
coat
a big hat and sunglasses so we're
walking through the parking lot the
oakbrook he's pure while back uh hey sly
how you doing man were you doing another
ride because then you realize
his head is 40 feet on the screen all
these years and they know every and he
does have a certain way he walks of
course right right but they probably
recognized you alongside him i didn't
recognize me at all no i was this was i
think before staying alive
but um
we had some funny times i mean
he used to wear those speedos oh what
well yeah he goes oh i've seen some
pictures he looks like a total
grease ball this is when he was really
built after doing rocky iii
and i was wearing like a real giant
bathing suit so we're in vegas
he goes all right i own this territory
he walks out this
bright like that color blue speedo
he's like ripped
and i'm there like wearing like like
balloon pants or something like that
but he's funny though i mean we have
we've had no you guys i love the
relationship that you it's weird i mean
that's why when we we don't talk it
really bugs me and thanks to your mother
your mother's kind of the peacekeeper
she is you know i think that because she
likes everyone being happy even though
she gets her mood stupidity we love
having you we always miss you when
you're not there yeah we have fun
because
he you know being that famous
he knows he can trust me i'm not a
snitch i'm not a rat i mean i've been
offered to
sell stories and he knows he can trust
me i know everything we know everything
about each other and that is a true
story they did put my hands in a cement
mixer and took all the skin off my hands
oh my god why would he do that because
he was he said dennis the menace he was
he did yeah you know like you see the
wheel the smith mixer the grooves that
kind of go in like that
i put my hands there
and he turned the wheel and it went
and i pulled my hands up one day you
need to prank him and get back i have to
say though for being a really good
guitarist you've been shot in the hand
you've had your hands in a cement mixer
yeah yeah you still play really well and
i think i try the unwaxers would love to
hear a little something you brought here
[Music]
one summer day
[Music]
in and fall
a reddit woman
she took phone
and now she's gone
[Music]
i can't worry
i'm sitting on
top of the world
[Music]
i can't think of a better way to wrap
the episode yeah seriously well girls
i'm very proud of you i'm happy i
finally did the show
is this like show 200 this is actually
almost 100 this is going to be in the
90s well thank you guys so much for
listening to us i love you i'm so happy
to have you on the show and we got some
exciting stuff coming up in the future
which uh i'm sure these young ladies
will yes eventually make sure you follow
him frank.stallone on instagram frank
stallone guitars watch stallone frank
that is the documentary on amazon prime
and we will see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you